the boys are back but it took a whole
lot of time and work to get to the final
product we see on our screens there's a
whole lot of cgi that is key for the
storytelling in the series so let's dive
right into what this superhero show
looked like without all the vfx
number one this certainly was a whale of
a job he's like so if we wanted to crash
a boat through a whale how hard would
that be
this might be one of the most
complicated scenes the team behind the
boys has ever pulled off but let's break
it down the boat that takes that whale
down it was real i think we took a
little creative license with that one it
emotionally it worked
and yes the actors were in it in fact
one of them was even manning it driving
like a total maniac all the boat stuff
was it was challenging to shoot but it
was uh we had so much fun doing that
thanks to a special slide built and set
up on the beach the boat could have a
somewhat controlled crash into the sea
creature
makes it so i mean pun intended i guess
impactful this ship was literally pulled
up onto the beach by a string while cg
gave us that water splashing but the
fake blood well they did 150 gallons of
practical blood on that shot which means
very little of the blood we see on
screen is cg number two if you can see
it you can do it the whale sequence you
know it was constantly evolving
anticipating one of the most intense
gruesome and memorable stunts meant
before diving in too far the team needed
to know exactly what they wanted to pull
off once we got the pages we were like
please will you come help us extremely
detailed pre-visuals were made so the
team could break the frames down and
determine exactly how to shoot the
sequence combining practical and visual
effects partnering with ilm once we got
the previz and the tech biz we also
shipped that to them everything on the
water wound up being cg but when we got
to the beach set that whale took center
stage
number three it's much easier on a
computer than in real life anyone can be
a superhero when you've got cg to help
you out who needs to spend all that time
and effort destroying real cars when you
can let electrifying cg powers do all
the heavy lifting in visual effects
sometimes you gotta do it sometimes
there's no other way literally the bit
of glow and lens flare we get when
seeing these powers on screen were added
purposefully to help bring a more
grounded feel to the show number four
how long could he hang on chase crawford
had the special privilege of being able
to film riding the whale on somewhat of
an actual whale he's a pretty cool dude
and he was just like all right cool man
whatever i think it was also just kind
of hilarious for him in what was the
only blue screenshot filmed in the
entire sequence is crawford sitting atop
a kind of mechanical bull whale 12 feet
up in the air chase just kind of trusted
us the actor had a solid grip feeling
that power as he filmed what would
become a very eye-catching shot guys yo
you know like big bear hug
and dolphins number five you gotta break
it down one step at a time launching
someone into a building is shockingly
easy to film that is if you consider an
actor making the leap out of a building
so the footage can be played in reverse
easy as for making the building explode
well it was a bit more complicated than
that the vfx version of the building
itself was the star of the show every
bit of the structure was detailed which
ensured the explosion and blast would
look as realistic as possible every beam
every stair and every cg brick was laid
before destroying it all anyway but for
a shot like this all that work is worth
it
number six three
two
one it's an efficient way to travel
you've got to give them that the fact
that it looks electrifyingly cool is
just a bonus wires were in place to
raise those performers up but the cool
effects well that was all the cg team
number seven need a skyscraper get a
skyscraper no problem eagle-eyed fans
might notice that the bottom of this
massive building looks awfully similar
to roy thompson hall in downtown toronto
but in the world of the boys the height
of this tower puts the real one to shame
that said the way the cg part of the
building matches the actual structure is
pretty impeccable oh and while we're
here let's check out another view of
that vaught headquarters building
number eight ship overboard
but on land real as it looks that boat
was nowhere near the set in this case a
large practical boat piece was enough of
a stand-in for the vfx team to work with
we forget that sometimes even seemingly
simple parts of shows like the boys have
some seriously detailed effects involved
when it came to the boat being thrown
right out of the water well cgi took the
stage for obvious reasons
number nine sometimes you gotta pave
your own path or blast it open in this
case after seeing a fiery first season
is it any surprise we get little
explosions everywhere this seems like a
bit of an odd choice but if you got the
ability to blast through metal then why
not
number 10 this is flexibility at a whole
new level k but for real though how do
actor sean benson's arms go on for so
long the magic of cg but those arms
didn't just get extended nah the vfx
team bulks up the arms a bit while
stretching them out oh and don't forget
to add some folks in the crowd probably
pull off more real
in camera when it came time to use those
arms to do some harm an extra person had
to help out acting as the actor's hands
while the rest of his body stayed hidden
in the green suit combined with the
actor's performance we'd never have
guessed there was another person between
them at all that's some laser focus
number 11 something every good superhero
should be able to do to pull off such an
epic feat without actual power requires
some heavy duty cg in this case a few
layers had to be combined to hit the
right mark the actors got to safely film
their portion in a green screen studio
while the vfx team got to work building
the world and crash so we got that extra
bit of pizzazz we loved so much the
performers definitely couldn't do it
alone what we see on screen is a combo
of the actual performer as well as cg
rendered portions that are layered over
top number 12. that light is mighty
bright sure aaron moriarty doesn't shine
quite literally as bright as she does in
the show but her performance even
without all the powers matches the level
of vfx her character was provided with
my character is the only good superhero
on the show she's earnestly like wants
to save the world not only did her eyes
get a glow up but her whole character as
we see all the cgi power taking over
moriarty was battling with everything
she had even if her powers weren't there
on the day she made it work with the
little square light patches on her hands
awesome it's fun it's really fun number
13. yeah you really don't want to get in
their way for the one shooting lasers
out of their eyes well cg looks much
cooler for those getting hurt by those
lasers it's not such a cute sight did a
tremendous job of getting right up to
the line if not over especially with the
creepy realistic prosthetics used before
any vfx took over thank goodness those
nasty injuries are just special effects
those laser burns do some serious damage
without cg it's just two people looking
at each other super intensely if looks
could hurt without lasers that is oh and
heating milk yeah it's never been easier
number 14. vfx was certainly less messy
than doing it in real life who knew so
much debris and dust had to be accounted
for when creating visual effects that
said it's certainly why the scene looks
so realistic it's mostly real we did a
little bit of sweetening and visual
effects but not much everything from
bits of debris to the vehicles
themselves to the climactic crash
wouldn't exist where enough for the cg
team behind the scenes in visual effects
sometimes you got to do it sometimes
there's no other way
number 15 vfx blasts don't stand a
chance against this superhero homelander
want to shake it up a bit no matter how
many shots the vfx team created to be
fired they didn't do any harm or slow
down the superhero at all to be honest i
think he's the weakest character on the
show i think you know super strength
these fiery details are key since they
helped to show us in the very beginning
of the series just how powerful anthony
star's character could be plus it looks
super rad that is a
wrap the cgi effects used in the boys
amp up this series to make it one of the
best there is these days we'd never have
guessed cg was used in so many instances
in the series but what we can say is
that all of them were done pretty
flawlessly
which scene had your favorite cgi work